the next opening in our top 10 list list
is the French defense probably one of
the more annoying defenses I think to
play against but Pawn to E4 and then
Pawn here to E6 getting ready if white
plays Pawn to D4 to push forward with
Pawn to D5 very solid defense from black
so I definitely recommend if you play
against E4 a lot that you study this
because it gives black a lot of
opportunities to counter on the queen
side very easy as these pawns are
pointed towards the queen side to push
forward with Pawn to C5 to get your dark
Square Bishop involved into the game to
even get your queen involved into the
game after you play your Pawn up here to
C5 so a lot of different ways the French
defense although I don't like playing
against it is a very very solid defense
against Pawn to
E4